[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring in mark
spears senior nba writer for the
undefeated how jealous are you
with uh meet friday there mark man i got
a trigger
i got a trigger okay i'm warming it up
tonight
now you inspired me to get some steaks
all right is that your go-to on the
traeger
yeah i'm i'm still i got to get past
novice status
uh my wife is talking bad about me like
not paying attention
to the app as well as i need to and the
thermometer
would you like to talk to my advisor my
traeger advisor because i'd be willing
to do that for you
yes okay i will this is with all
seriousness
yes absolutely i don't joke when it
comes to barbecue
no no now it depends on how good you are
in this segment if you're good then i'm
going to give you my advisor's
number okay no pressure mark okay oh
man oh man all right here we go we're
going to play a game hey man can i say
it's a
uh it's a pleasure to talk to you man
you're a legend in this business so
it's pleasure thank you mark i did i did
see
your michael jordan's story
and it it i always tell my jordan's
story of how competitive he is
yeah and after he hit the shot in utah
we thought his career was
over he ended on a championship jumper
and we were ready to go on sportscenter
and i'm going to interview him
and he comes in he's drenched in
champagne his jersey's out
basketball in his arm cuban cigar
does the interview and he gets up and i
don't know what to say because i think
this is the last time
he's going to play a game so i said man
it's a shame you're
retiring and he turns he goes why is
that
i said i know i'd like a piece of you he
goes what the
and said stand up so i'm in my suit and
tie
so i got phil jackson ready to go on
sportscenter with me we just went to
commercial break
stand up so i stood up he goes how the
bleep would you guard me
so i put my arm in his back like a
forearm bar
and he goes i would and then he just
there are a lot of mfr's in there
and then he walked out the door and i
sat down i went
what just happened what just happened
and phil jackson goes
you see what i i dealt with all the time
tell your michael jordan's story well it
is it's actually a story i got from
mctarenzy
nick scout former north carolina player
and you know as you know dean smith
always had former players come in
so one day um michael jordan came in
just to visit with the players and he
goes by and dean has him
shake all the guys hands and hey what's
your name i'm anton jamison nice to meet
you
hey what's your name i'm vince carter
nice to meet you well makdar is crazy
man he goes to the end of the line and
jordan comes up to me goes hey what's
your name he's like
maktar enjoy what's your name
uh michael nice to meet you michael
and michael goes well um
where are you from senegal well they
must not have much basketball in senegal
if you don't know
who i am he goes yeah yeah nice to meet
you but
and the kim elijah wants the greatest
player of all time by the way
jordan gets pissed off runs into the
back
puts on some practice gear comes out
tells dean smith give me your walk-ons
the guys at the end of your bench i'm
playing your starters
so he proceeds to play with like serge
wicker
and some other guys i don't remember and
apparently they played
serge wicker looked like a number one
pick in the draft next to jordan right
and they're killing vince carter and
vince is pissed at
mack because he has to guard him right
but
jordan's trying to dunk on mac doesn't
doesn't matt gets out of the way
jordan basically shows mctarr and
everybody else who he is
in case they didn't know and he's in his
prime with the bulls at the time
and um so years later uh
anton jameson had a day off with the
wizards
he goes to miami for super bowl weekend
and mac tarz with him
so they're trying to get in this club
and
jordan comes out from the rooftop and
they basically like mike mike mike can
you let us in can you let us in
and jordan yells down to mctart oh now
you remember my name
uh africa why don't you go tell akeem to
help you get in and walks back in
so i heard jameson was mad at baktar for
getting that story out but this is
hoop stories in the undefeated we got a
couple they're car
animated which i think makes it funnier
and last one was on james harden's
bodyguard getting beat up
san francisco and uh hopefully uh espn
will get behind it and we'll have more
soon man i'm glad you enjoyed it
yeah that was great um how about we play
fill in the blank
okay all right the greek freak is the
blank player in the world
he's the best now he's the best i but
but
i also thought i kind of think of your
finals mvp you own that
that title for the summer unless it's
andre iguodala
yeah it's not it's his title for the
summer he follows everything
that's just how i feel about it i mean
kevin durant's the best in the world to
me
i'd i'd still take him over anybody but
i was
impressed with giannis's giannis finally
getting out of his own way and going
inside i thought shooting the threes is
certainly not his game being
easy to guard by taking those long steps
and letting people jump in front of them
he did what my coach always told me to
do in college in high school get your
butt in the post
yeah and once he got his butt in the
post man he dominated
there was nothing they could do he
doesn't score a 50 if he's shooting
jumpers
no and and we've bought into this game
plan and that's what you have to do and
i said the same thing on the show i said
nobody can guard him down low and and if
you miss your first shot
you'll get your second shot they
dominated on the offensive glass
it was like i'm not going to play into
your strategy you got to play into my
strategy and yeah
and that's why i mean he was he was
exceptional for a guy who didn't have a
go-to move
he he certainly scored dan he
neutralized his superpower by shooting
jump
yes you know and so i i think this
this series was bad for the analytic
people you had giannis scoring in the
post
uh obviously middleton and chris paul
and booker hit a lot of mid-range
jumpers
um so you can't tell me that scoring in
the post
and making mid-range jumpers is not
valuable on this level anymore
we're talking to mark spears senior nba
writer for the undefeated
you had a lot of chatter about what the
lakers could do in the off-season
could do yes sir um let's
let's look at how about what what
should they do and then we if it's
different from what they will do
what should they do well what they
should do is find a veteran point guard
you know they got this window now that's
that's not that wide open
um obviously health i think ruined
everything for them this year they could
have potentially repeated
but they're looking for a veteran point
guard and they need to
i've heard that russell westbrook's on
that list i've heard that chris paul is
on that list
obviously it's not easy as just making
some trade
but they do have some assets you know
dennis schroeder could do a sign trade
um kyle kuzma is an interesting young
player
i've seen enough of and i think you've
seen enough of taylor horton tucker
where i think with the kids like 20 and
he's a bucket getter man so um
they have some pieces that they could
move it's not
trading at a.d or lebron but um
i'd be intrigued to see if washington
especially if bill
wants to go could be interested in
moving russell back home
chris chris paul's is more complicated
yeah i don't like russell
going his tempo is different than than
lebron so that
that would concern me um chris paul
yeah but i could like kyle lowry
makes maybe a little more sense than
than
yeah exactly um malcolm brogdon
mike conley maybe i don't know yeah but
it just feels like it's going to be
tricky like when it's all said and done
what do you think the lakers look like
next season is kyle kuzma there
schroeder there
no no shooter already took the
lakers off his instagram page man he's
letting you know
i i think for kyle man and i'm not
speaking for kyle but
i think he needs to get out of that
laker shadow same way
brandon ingram flourished afterwards the
same way
julius randle um jordan clarkson like
they all flourished after they left
but i think they like it i think kyle
kuzma likes
being a laker even though being a laker
is not the best thing for his career
does that make sense
i think he likes it off the court yeah
but
he seems to play much better when he's a
starter so
you know it's interesting that you meant
mention the kyle lowry
thing um if kyle says i want to be a
laker
i think messiah ugeri respects him and
helps him make that happen
and the one thing that helps the raptors
is hey they do have some assets that we
could get back
to to help our team and and you know not
lose kyle for nothing
let me get your damien lillard
prediction
man i known dame since he came into the
league i saw i was at that famous
workout
at merrick college in oakland that was
the greatest workout i've ever seen
he's he told me that he's loyal but not
to a fault and i think the loyalty has
run out
um i think there's certainly a lot of
pressure on the blazers to make
something happen
to make it attractive going into next
season but what can they do
they don't have a lot of assets they
don't have much they could trade i mean
you could only get so much for cj
mccullum
team pretty much needs an overhaul their
bigs are always hurt
i don't know if they could do enough in
time so
after this olympic experience it's not
going to help the blazers
he's next to kd he's next to like
draymond
he's next to guys like hey why don't you
come play here why don't you
you know let me see what i could do so i
i'm i'm really nervous for the blazers
right now but perhaps what giannis did
might
give damn another breath but he
basically told him you got to make some
moves man like i'm i'm not coming back
with this team
um the warriors are intriguing for me
because it feels like they want to do
something now i thought they would
compete for the title if everybody was
healthy this last year right
i thought that that that much of that
roster
but it just feels like can they package
some players some picks can they
can they take a big swing here in the
off season
i'm i'm actually not going to go to the
draft
because the world is crazy right now i
live in the bay but i am going to go to
the warriors media availability because
to your point i think they're going to
do something
and i i think they might have the
blockbuster move
they have seven they have 14. they
wiggins had a solid season wiseman i
think is going to be special
i saw enough from him that i think and
especially when you see what happened
with eight and you got to be patient
with biggs
i think they're fine if they leave their
team alone like clay is gonna be back
wiseman's gonna be better i don't know
that they really need to make a
blockbuster
move in fact i would just be patient and
perhaps
wait into mid-season but what if
somebody dangles beale what if
the blazers like hey what about dame for
some of that young
but they they have assets to to make a
move
and i'm sure that they're having a lot
of conversations if there is a team
that's going to make a move
i put them on the list and i put
washington on the list too
before i let you go i know you wrote a
column on
lsu star cameron thomas it's not just
about him being a top nba draft pick
it's
it's more about his mom and the role
that she's played in and making him
become
that kind of man yeah no leslie thomas
basically uh how many moms you know
like took rebounds uh yells at her son
for making free throw
not making free throws because they're
free and so from the beginning when he
was two years old she groomed him
into being the star and and there are
nba teams that wonder
is cameron thomas who averaged 23 points
who
who was a first-team all-sec who led off
freshman scoring
is mom going to get in the way well i
think in this story you see that
mom is actually pushing them to the next
level and uh
and she's an army friendship yeah she
was in the army for four years
uh will wade said is the most
disciplined freshman he's ever had the
coach of lsu
he said this kid shows up 20 minutes
early to practice
uh like what freshman does that like so
i think his mom has
instilled some army values that along
with his
scoring ability is is going to make him
a very intriguing prospect on thursday
uh fritz is going to reach out to you
and i'm going to put you on so i got it
i i think by all accounts i'll pass the
test
let's vote let's vote if spears gets to
talk to our
barbecue advisor chad at traeger paulie
he nailed the jordan story
right to the point okay fritzy
absolutely okay seton crush get the man
the number
all right i was gonna say no but uh you
know but that's three out of four yeah
uh
my vote counts as two just let you know
mark um yeah but i still but i still
passed i know you did you did so
my lsu san jose state math i think i
feel bad
wow i'm gonna uh i'm gonna have fritzy
reach out to our uh our traeger advisor
he's actually a champion griller and uh
he'd be more than happy to help you
in uh giving you some advice man you
made my day brother
have a great weekend mark thanks for
joining us pleasure
mark spears senior nba writer for the
undefeated